[Musique]
les unes de la presse avec hélène frade
bonjour allen bonjour des liens est la
une ce matin notamment le volte face de
la caméra qui vient de taper contre un
poteau mais aussi celui de la suède et
de la finlande provoqué par la guerre en
ukraine volte face qui pourrait amener
les deux pays nordiques à renoncer à
leur politique historique de non
alignement d'après 104 acb la dette la
première ministre finlandaise anna
marine et son homologue suédoise
anderson se seraient mises d'accord hier
lors de leur rencontre à stockholm pour
que leurs pays rejoignent l'otan selon
le quotidien les sociaux démocrates
auraient même décidé de déposer
rapidement la candidature suédoise qui
pourrait être soumise lors du sommet de
l'étang de l'otan prévue à la fin du
mois de juin à madrid si la finlande et
la suède se décide à postuler
officiellement leur candidature pourrait
être acceptée en un temps record d'après
le corriere della sera cité par courrier
international
d'après le quotidien italien l'adhésion
d'helsinki et de stockholm serait même
une simple formalité dans la mesure où
les deux pays scandinaves participent
déjà en tant qu'observateur aux
exercices militaires de l'otan et où
celle ci a déjà signalé qu'elle les
accueillerait à bras ouverts la finlande
et la suède ont leur place dans l'otan
confirment le washington post le
quotidien américain affirme que
l'agression de l'ukraine par vladimir
poutine s'est finalement retournée
contre lui en augmentant la probabilité
que le temps s'étendent effectivement
jusqu'aux frontières de la russie une
perspective que les états unis et le
reste de l'alliance devraient saluer
selon le journal qui rappelle non moi
d'amener un collègue candidatures des
deux pays scandinaves n'est pas une
mince affaire pour washington étant
donné l'obligation futur de les défendre
contre les attaques extérieures
conformément à l'article 5 du traité de
l'atlantique nord apolline l'évoqué tout
à l'heure l'otan que marine le pen
souhaite voir se rapprocher de la russie
avant la fin de la guerre en ukraine
après la fin de la guerre en ukraine
longtemps accusé de mansuétude envers le
régime russe la candidate à la
présidentielle française a exprimé ce
souhait dans le cadre de la présentation
de sa politique de la politique
étrangère qu'elle mettrait en oeuvre si
elle est élue
une déclaration va reprise par le
quotidien espagnol el país qui rapporte
que la patronne jahren dit aussi vouloir
mettre fin à la coopération militaire
avec l'allemagne en raison je la cite de
divergences stratégiques
irréconciliables
notamment sur le nucléaire et transformé
également l'union européenne en une
alliance européenne des nations aux
états unis aient droit aux sept journal
souligne que marine le pen souhaite
également retiré la france du
commandement intégré de l'otan au motif
que sa participation porte atteinte à la
souveraineté de la france et risque de
l'entraîner dans des conflits contre son
gré le quotidien américain voit dans
l'ascension de marine le pen la preuve
envoyé à une grande partie de l'europe
que le scepticisme vis-à-vis de la
confrontation avec moscou n'est pas
pénalisée dans les urnes et qu'il existe
des fissures dans le soutien populaire à
la coalition occidentale contre la
russie il ya aussi déficient au sein des
occidentaux entre joe biden qui est que
je vais dire poutine de génocide
emmanuel macron qui dit refuser l
escalade des mots le terme employé par
le président américain était également
accueilli avec beaucoup de prudence par
le quotidien belge le soir qui n'exclut
pas je cite qu'une extermination
silencieuse puisse être en cours
parallèlement aux combats qui ont lieu
en ukraine le journal demande toutefois
à joe biden de fournir la preuve de ce
qu'il avance faute de quoi il
contribuerait à maintenir l'opacité sur
l'assassinât sans précédent qu'il
dénonce le soir c'est l'hypothèse que le
président américain puisse donner dans
la surenchère et la propagande comme les
états unis l'avaient fait lors de la
guerre en irak en 2003 et il cite le
journaliste français albert londres mal
nommer les choses c'est ajouter du
malheur au monde le quotidien français
la croix à situer le clean le
mathématicien grec ce qui est affirmé
sans preuve peut être nié sans preuve le
journal reconnaît que le renseignement
américain a fait la preuve de son
efficacité ces dernières semaines mais
prévient que rien ne serait pire que de
décrédibiliser le travail prudent et
minutieux des enquêteurs des juges et
des journalistes sur place le travail
patient et minutieux des journalistes
également malmenées en algérie ou on en
parlait déjà ces derniers jours le
quotidien liberté titre phare de la
presse francophone indépendante
algérienne publié aujourd'hui son
dernier numéro merci et au revoir titre
simplement le quotidien qui a porté
pendant 30 ans les idéaux de démocratie
de liberté c'est une page exaltante qui
se tourne écrit le journal en dénonçant
je cite les coups de boutoir d'une
politique médiatique pour le mois au
style inefficiente et surtout
dommageable pour les intérêts de
l'algérie on se quitte pas là dessus
elle après avoir révélé que le ministère
de la défense de son pays avait fait
l'achat de quelque 35000 pilules de
viagra députés brésiliens s'étaient pas
des gardiennes affirme à présent que
l'armée brésilienne a également acheté
60 un plan peignant gonflable d'une
valeur unitaire de dix à douze mille
euros ces prothèses aurait coûté damien
près de 700000 euros gouvernement
brésilien au total le ministère de la
défense qui avait expliqué au sujet du
viagra que ces acquisitions était
destiné au traitement de patients
atteints d'hypertension artérielle
pulmonaire jaillard et n'a pas encore
commenté ces achats de prothèse pénienne
à une obligation sans doute de se tenir
au garde à vous merci beaucoup élèves